SPEAKER: In this
video, we'll explain
how to defer a subscription
renewal date for a user.
This is often used as a
customer service tool in case
the user experiences
issues with your service.
For example, if
the user contacts
you to ask for help during
a known service outage,
you can respond by deferring
their subscription renewal.
Using the Google
Play Developer API,
you can advance the next
billing date for a subscriber.
The user continues to be
subscribed to the content
and has full access to
it but is not charged
during the deferral period.
The subscription
renewal date will
be updated to reflect
the new billing date that
was passed to the API.
You can advance the renewal date
by as little as one day or as
long as one year per API call.
Once this is done,
you may want to notify
the user of this change to
their billing either in the app
or through email.
To learn more, visit
the link onscreen,
or check out our other videos.